[Musique] d'
accord, on
m'a tiré dessus, quelqu'un m'a lancé un
micro-ondes, alors je vais juste dire
quelque chose que ma mère avait l'habitude de dire et
espérer le meilleur ici chaque fois que vous avez de
bonnes dépenses pour le voyageur que ma mère a
dit et aidé  la personne des voyageurs
sans maison c'est tout je suis
sûr que vous l'avez vu traverser des choses
auxquelles vous ne faites pas confiance aux gens je comprends
je comprends
j'ai vécu des choses elle a aussi dit
que ma miséricorde l'emporte sur ma colère
peut-être  c'est pas tout ma maman celle là
qui est du coran je n'aurais pas dû
dire que je ne te connais même pas mais je
n'ai pas mangé depuis quelques jours et tu
n'es peut être même pas vraiment
beau
toi